[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we'll be discussing
professor phillius flitwick
resident charms master of hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry and
head
of ravenclaw house phillius comes from
the latin word for
sun and it has been expressed that his
name is derived from
villius philosophorum which means the
philosopher's son
a symbol in alchemy when new students
are first sorted into ravenclaw
they are introduced to their head of
house in the following manner
speaking of eccentrics you'll like our
head of house professor philia splitwick
people often underestimate him because
he's really tiny we think he's part elf
but we've never been rude enough to ask
he's got a squeaky voice but he's the
best and most knowledgeable charms
master alive
in the world today his office door is
always open to any ravenclaw with a
problem
and if you're in a real state he'll get
out these delicious little cupcakes he
keeps in a tin in his desk drawer
and make them do a little dance for you
in fact it's worth pretending you're in
a real state
just to see them jive flipwick is an
interesting character as
though he is quite prevalent not a lot
of information is ever revealed about
him
or his backstory at least not too
directly
however what we can do is piece together
flipbook story
with the little tidbits that were
sporadically given filius was born
somewhere in the british isles to the
whistling family the flipwicks
his small stature can be attributed to
what rolling has described as a
dash of goblin blood stemming back to
what we believe to be his great
great great grandparent clearly goblin
blood is quite potent
as despite preceding phillies's
existence by several generations
it still had a profound impact on his
physical stature
we don't know which of filius's parents
carried the goblin blood
or exactly how far back it would have
been introduced to his bloodline
but we do know that it stemmed from long
before phillies we don't know what year
he was born
because we don't actually know how old
philly's phobic is and this is further
complicated by the fact that the
character we see on screens
and films is portrayed in two very
different ways
we're first introduced to flipbook right
at the beginning of the books and films
in harry potter and the philosopher's
stone then we see the same flipwick
return
and harry potter in the chamber of
secrets this version of flitwick is
grey-bearded
bald and clearly quite old perhaps even
giving dumbledore a run for his money
but then out of nowhere the prisoner of
azkaban introduces us to an entirely
different
new flitwick much younger version of the
professor
sporting a full head of brown hair and a
large curled moustache
they did a bit of one ac on his
character but i've personally become
much more familiar with the younger
brown head flitwick that was present for
the majority of the films
but while we don't know flitwick's exact
age there is a lot of speculation
floating around that he was born
sometime between
1935 and 1958. this is a wide range
i know 1958 seems late because this
would mean that he was only 40
during the battle of hogwarts which
makes no sense to me 1935 on the other
hand
would make him 63 during the battle of
hogwarts which doesn't quite match his
newer appearance
i'm thinking that i personally feel best
about splitting the difference
and assuming that flipbook was born in
the year 1946
which would make him 52 during the
battle of hogwarts for some perspective
this would make him five years older
than belichick's estranged two
years older than alistair moody and 11
years younger than mcgonagall
assuming she was born in 1935. this
seems about right
like most other characters flipwick also
attended hogwarts in his youth
due to his goblin heritage flitwick was
initially treated like a second-class
citizen
by many the result of stigma towards
goblins in the wizarding community
goblins while they appear to have at
least a grudging coexistence with the
wizarding world
have nonetheless experienced much
discrimination from wizards
and many have led significant uprisings
against them in the past
however despite the discrimination that
flitwick experienced first hand
he had no issues at the school this was
no doubt the result of his incredibly
thick skin
and the ability to perceive those who
treated him differently as ignorant
simpletons
rather than malicious sectarians this
was a testament to footwork's overall
tolerance
he was a man that could handle a lot and
what he endured in his life made him
very tough
so tough in fact that it was revealed to
us in the chamber of secrets
that flipwick was once a dueling
champion flitwick was a dueling champion
when he was young
he supposedly has a shelf full of
trophies to prove it during flipbook
sorting ceremony the sorting hat did
take some time to sort flip wick
though it should be noted that no hats
at all occurred a hat stall occurs when
the sorting hat needs additional time to
come up with a decision
usually five minutes or longer and
though with flip wicket took some extra
time
it didn't need five minutes it occurs
when a student has a personality
that can be considered equally suitable
for each of the hogwarts houses
and in flitwick's case the hat viewed
flitwick as a nearly equally suitable
candidate for both ravenclaw and
gryffindor
gryffindor house has an emphasis on
bravery as a character trait
and ravenclaw has an emphasis on
intelligence and knowledge
though flitwick was exceedingly brave
his intelligent in studio's mind
ended up being a better fit for
ravenclaw house where he would later
feel right at home
flipwick was a promising young student
who achieved high grades in both his owl
and
newt exams showcasing exceptional
ability across a multitude of subjects
however what flipbook really excelled in
was charms
charms are spells which add certain
properties to objects or individuals
charms should not be confused with
transfigurations as transfiguration
refers to a spell that changes what the
object is rather than just changing
properties of the object
there are countless charms in harry
potter and we see flitwick exercising
his charms
abilities while casting defensive
enchantments over hogwarts
before its attack by voldemort and the
death eaters flipbook is thought to be
one of the most talented charms teachers
had ever taught at hogwarts and had no
difficulty producing even the most
complex
complicated and powerful shield charms
after graduating from hogwarts flitwick
became a master duelist
and dove further into other areas of
magic eventually mastering some of the
trickiest areas
like defense against the dark arts and
it was flippage knowledge of the dark
arts
that allowed him to personally defeat a
handful of death eaters during the siege
on hogwarts
from there flip found himself right back
at his old stomping grounds
taking up the post of charms master at
hogwarts in classroom 2e
flipwick's classroom was located in the
charms corridor on the third floor of
the training grounds tower
the same tower where the library is
located flitwick was a gifted professor
and commanded a great deal of respect
from both his colleagues and students
not only was he an excellent teacher but
he was also considerably more tolerant
and patient than some of the other
professors during charms lessons
flitwood was a target of many misfired
spells that were produced at the hands
of ron weasley
devil longbottom james finnegan and
others
flipwick was also far more tolerant of
disobedience and would rarely deduct
house points or give his students
detention
flipbook's class was among hermione's
favorites as she praised him as a
professor
it also helped that she did particularly
well in his class
knowing that hermione was very talented
with charm work he would sometimes turn
a blind eye
to her showing up late to class or
missing it all together
it was this attitude that made him very
well liked by the student body
additionally due to flipwick's
introduction to discrimination
very early on in his life he was
particularly conscious of
and fair when it came to the
consideration of students houses
he had no bias towards students of his
house and treated all students the same
as he should flipwick taught at the
school for many many years
and in 1998 helped with the defense of
hogwarts against death eaters
flitwick played a pivotal role in the
defense of hogwarts as he was able to
help defeat numerous death eaters
including the powerful antonin dolohov
this is a true testament
to flipbx abilities after the battle of
hogwarts
flipwick simply resumed his post as
charm's master at the school
he was a passionate and devoted
professor that loved educating new
generations on charm work
and after the battle he still had plenty
of life left in him
flipwick the tiny little wizard who had
to stand on a pile of books to see over
his desk
was one of the best things to ever
happen to the school and that's it for
this video
which backstory do you guys want next if
you enjoy the content please remember to
like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
your withered harry
you